-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, let's get to the news.
Former President Trump
released a letter last week,
urging Texas
Governor Greg Abbott
to audit the results
of the 2020 election, and said,
"We're quickly running
out of time."
You're running out of time?
The election was a year ago.
Also, you won Texas.
What are you hoping they find?
"Well, we reran the numbers
and this is crazy --
there's like
40,000 Georgia votes here."
[ Laughter ]
Former President Obama
announced on Friday
he will hold a groundbreaking
ceremony this week
for his presidential library.
Meanwhile, the Trump Library
was deleted from the Internet.
[ Laughter ]
88-year-old Iowa
Senator Chuck Grassley
announced on Friday that he will
run for reelection next year.
I mean, you have to appreciate
his optimism.
If I was 88, I think I would
buy eggs one at a time.
[ Laughter ]
Former New York mayoral
candidate Andrew Yang
will reportedly launch
a new political party
that he will call
The Forward Party.
I always thought Republicans
were the forward party.
[ Laughter ]
Producers of the Netflix series
"Tiger King" announced last week
that the show will return later
this year for a second season.
"Well, that can't be good,"
said Carole Baskin's
current husband.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
using a sauna
at least twice a week
can have cardiovascular benefits
similar to exercise,
because nothing will get
your heart rate going
like the scary things
you'll see in there.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, very artfully done,
graphics department.
[ Laughter ]
A Rhode Island home
that was the inspiration
for the movie and book
"The Conjuring"
stole -- sold recently
for $1.2 million.
Even more terrifying --
the list price was
[ Spookily ]
$900,000.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
according to a new poll,
75% of Americans would call
the season between summer
and winter, fall,
while 21% will call it autumn.
Of course,
Walgreens just calls it
Christmas.
And that was a monologue.